so that's how you you can help in that
situation there's something else that I
want to do though which is I want to
punish Duke for what they're doing I
think actually it's not not enough just
to just to help the people who have
clearly been victimized here but you
need to make sure that this is not
permitted to continue into the future we
were talking earlier on the show about
retribution and I think Duke deserves
some serious Justice for their crimes
here okay and so from a political
standpoint how do we stop medical
centers from from doing this so we have
retained a lawyer Mike Yoder and he is
working that right now uh appearance and
damages to Duke and uh so we're that's
that's ongoing right now that's what
we're trying to do I know to help to
hold Duke accountable for this you know
travesty in my mind but people can call
Duke if they want to as well and let
their opinions be known but we just ask
that there's no foul language use or any
death threats um we want to keep this
civil but for Duke to understand that
we're not alone there's other people in
this country that also agree with what
we're doing right and that is an
important point you you've got to make
sure that uh when you engage in these
political actions you don't give the
leftists the opportunity to paint you as
a terrorist or all the way that they
ordinarily talk about us though
conservatives don't really need to be
told this I think conservatives
generally know this but it's always good
to repeat because I I remember not that
long ago here in Nashville we discovered
that Vanderbilt Children's Hospital was
performing transgender procedures on
little kids and this is this is
Tennessee okay we're talking about a
pretty red State here and and we
discovered this and we found it people
just didn't really know about it and so
we we gathered a lot of information my
colleague Matt Walsh has made the
transgender issue something of a hobby
horse of his and had a big movie come
out about it so he just published a
Twitter thread with the the research
that the daily wire had compiled and the
moment we shed a light on this
like within days the Vanderbilt
University just caved because they
didn't want and I I just suspect if if
people in North Carolina taxpayers
donors even to Duke Medical politicians
who have a lot to say about the conduct
here if they just knew that this was
happening I cannot imagine how it would
be tolerated for much longer I agree I
agree with you we have had a couple of
legislators reach out to us but we've
heard no more from them so I don't know
I hope that something does happen that
we're out as well how is your daughter
doing through all of this
um she's doing amazing she I said on
other interviews too she's the most
amazing little girl she's been through
so much in her life we're her third
family in America uh I mean she's she's
been through so much but she just pushes
through with a smile on her face she's
always happy always wanting to help so
involved with all the other kids in the
family I mean she really is just an
amazing person
you you mentioned that you're the third
family how did you come to adopt her
wow that's a long story but uh so the
first family they would I met them in
Ukraine in 2018 we adopted our first uh
daughter from Ukraine and uh there was
another family that adopted him here in
North Carolina
that didn't work out they sent uh her to
Arizona to another family to potentially
adopt her it that didn't work out so
they were on the thing on a plane back
to North Carolina the family here that
originally adopted her uh was not able
to go pick them up at the airport so we
did because I knew who they were her and
her brother and so we picked them up at
the airport we thought we were going to
be keeping for a weekend just to kind of
figure out what we're gonna you know who
was going to adopt and what we're going
to do in the next steps and we ended up
being the family that they uh they ended
up going to so I'm grateful for that I
have total family size Envy right now uh
we you know I got I got married we got
started a little bit later I I hope to
catch up I think uh it's just a matter
of biology I'm not quite sure we could
get up to eight biological children so
you've adopted as well now your family
size is unusual by today's stand by
historical standards it's not but by
modern liberal Society standards it
certainly is what has impelled you to
have such a large family God
simply answer the God I mean it was
never our plan to have a big family but
my husband was military and we traveled
around the world and
um our oldest son kept praying for a
brother and they just kept coming so
there we go three girls three little
girls of seven seven boys we wouldn't
have it any other way though like our
life is life is crazy and chaotic and
amazing and beautiful
that that is amazing and you mentioned
your military service so thank you thank
you for your service it even drives home
the point further than it already was
in in political stories sometimes the
details are kind of complicated and
these These are nuanced issues and
questions
and sometimes it's just
pretty clear who the good guys are and
the bad guys are and I mean if if you if
you took this story to a Hollywood
producer and you said hey I got this
story about a family military veterans
you know big loving family adopted
children a poor little girl who needs a
kidney transplant and then a bunch of
doctors who out of out of a vindictive
biteful tyranny are demanding that she
inject herself with a dangerous drug or
they won't give her her kidney and and
that's going to be the movie The you
know what the Hollywood producer would
say the producer would say come on it's
a little too on the nose come on let's
make it a little more realistic here
okay
but but this is what's really happening
to you
it is really happening this is real life
yeah have other families Julia all the
time that she used to write her she
should write about her autobiography so
maybe she'll actually get that out of
this yeah she's a she's a ferocious
reader and she does write books Yeah you
mentioned other families who are in a
similar position have any of them
reached out to you as a result of the
publicity yes there's one little boy
who's only two years old in South
Carolina and they are they will not give
him a transplant either without the
vaccine which is unconscionable to me
he's two years old
um I've been talking to that grandfather
a lot we were trying to get him to
another Medical Institute and he's
trying to fight
um The Tyranny down there in South
Carolina as well
I didn't even know the vaccine was
approved for two-year-olds much less I
would mandate it
I know right it's it's horrific I think
the CDC is now recommended down to six
months old yeah for this vaccine
six which is unconscious yeah that's
unconscionable to me I can't believe
that what's amazing about it too I mean
you you say that uh obviously you're a
religious family God is at the center of
of so much that has happened in your in
your family but
humility is the beginning of wisdom the
fear of the Lord is the beginning of
wisdom and you would just think that
after two years of the experts in the
lab coats being proven wrong and in some
cases being proven to have lied about
and and to have been negligent about
this virus and this vaccine repeatedly
time and time again on the safety on the
efficacy on the the way that the
technology would even work on what the
virus is on where the virus came from on
how to stop getting the virus on
everything just every single thing about
it
they might have just a little bit of
humility and loosen their grip and their
demands just a little bit but it seems
that it's only gone in the opposite
direction it seems that they've only
only clamped down even further yeah it's
I really feel like it's a power struggle
at this point like they they want their
way and we're not going to do it so then
they're going to withhold what we need
have you raised significant amount of
money yet to to be able to afford going
to Texas or Florida
yes we really have people have been very
ways very much I mean we're overwhelmed
by the generosity of perfect strangers
and had the words of encouragement that
have come to us
um it's been amazing there have been
some nasty comments but I would say it's
ten to one in support of us of course I
can't even imagine who the nasty
comments are from maybe it's just Dr
fauci with his pseudonymous accounts or
something you know what I mean a lot of
times they don't give their real email
it's just like a made-up email and
there's a lot of foul language and you
know but we just delete it and move on